el pasado 10 de agosto una fatídica
noticia recorrió todo el mundo Asesinan
al candidato presidencial Fernando
villavicencio tras un mitin en Ecuador
desde luego que no es la primera vez que
en América Latina se atenta contra un
candidato presidencial en Colombia en
los años 80 y 90 se produjeron los
asesinatos de Jaime pardo Leal Bernardo
Jaramillo Osa o Luis Carlos galán en
México más de lo mismo Incluso hoy
muchos candidatos siguen sufriendo
atentados contra su vida la inmensa
mayoría Eso sí son candidatos locales de
hecho en el año 2021 Ni más ni menos que
27 candidatos a las elecciones locales
fueron asesinados en México sin embargo
el trágico asesinato de villavicencio es
especialmente importante porque refleja
la nueva realidad en la que vive Ecuador
Ecuador Es un país que ha pasado de ser
uno de los más pacíficos de toda América
Latina a uno de los más violentos y esto
ha sido un enorme cambio de paradigma
que se ha dado en muy pocos años para
que os hagáis una idea en cuestión de
solo cuatro años Ecuador se ha
convertido en el tercer país más
violento de América Latina continental
sus tasas de homicidio superan ya a las
de México y Colombia es una una
barbaridad y ahora son muchos los
Ecuatorianos que están perplejos ante la
deriva que ha tomado el país el
asesinato de Fernando villavicencio ha
sido una Clara muestra al mundo de cómo
se están poniendo las cosas en este país
y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
todos en este momento qué demonios ha
pasado en Ecuador para pasar de ser uno
de los países más pacíficos de
latinoamérica a ser el tercer más
violento Por qué han asesinado a
Fernando villavicencio Qué significa
realmente el trágico asesinato de este
candidato Pues bien hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el método correa
si hablamos de regiones violentas en los
últimos años América Latina se ha
llevado La Palma por diferencia Por
supuesto que hay países en mejor y en
peor situación países como México
Colombia Brasil Honduras o Guatemala no
suelen salir muy bien parados vamos que
suelen liderar el ranking de los países
más violentos Ecuador sin embargo ha
vivido una historia muy diferente
Ecuador no ha sido un país excesivamente
violento al menos si lo comparamos con
sus vecinos regionales y no lo ha sido
por una razón principal la reducida
presencia del narcotráfico en este país
seguro que no sorprendo si os digo que
el negocio del narco se desarrolló mucho
más en su vecino del Norte que es
Colombia y es que veréis aunque Es
cierto que hay algunos pequeños cultivos
de hoja de coca en Ecuador la realidad
es que no ha destacado nunca por ser un
gran productor como si lo es Colombia o
su otro vecino El Perú de esta forma
Ecuador se ha limitado a ser
especialmente desde principios del
presente siglo del siglo XXI un lugar de
tránsito para todo tipo de sustancias
prohibidas procedentes de Los Dos
Grandes productores que tiene como
vecinos no obstante Y aunque el papel de
Ecuador haya sido fundamentalmente el de
tránsito fue justo después de principios
de este siglo cuando las pandillas
habitualmente vinculadas al mundo del
narcotráfico comenzaron a extender la
violencia por todo el país hablamos de
pandillas como los famosos Latin Kings o
los choneros dos grupos que llevaron al
país a un escenario en que cada año se
superaban los 2000 homicidios la
histórica tranquilidad de Ecuador se
había terminado Sin embargo a partir de
2007 la situación cambiaría
drásticamente y por qué Pues porque
llegó la presidencia uno de los
principales líderes del llamado
socialismo del siglo XXI quedaría un
vuelco de 180 grados a la estrategia de
seguridad del país
la llegada de Rafael Correa a la
presidencia de Ecuador en 2007 comenzó
con una de las medidas más polémicas y
revolucionarias vistas en materia de
seguridad Correa rápidamente comenzó un
proceso de legalización de pandillas
como los nietas o los Latin Kings para
que dejaran de estar en la
clandestinidad y pasar a ser
asociaciones juveniles implicadas en el
proceso político además en 2011 lanzó su
plan de seguridad integral con el que
pretendía dejar atrás la mano dura que
caracterizó a los gobiernos Ecuatorianos
anteriores para centrarse en la mejora
de las condiciones educativas sanitarias
y laborales para combatir el aumento del
crimen estas y otras medidas como la
reforma del Código Penal de 2014
lograron finalmente que el número de
homicidios cayera en los años siguientes
de forma sustancial incluso por debajo
de la Barrera de los 1000 homicidios en
2016 es decir una cifra en torno a los
cinco homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes un nivel alto pero comparable
al de países como Argentina o chile
sin embargo mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik esto no duró demasiado por
qué Pues porque a partir del año 2018 en
Ecuador se produjo una mezcla de
factores que acabaron por crear un
cóctel de violencia absolutamente
explosivo entre la elevada informalidad
de la economía la precariedad y la
pobreza que se sitúa en torno al 30% de
la población muchos grupos criminales
ligados al narcotráfico Se abrieron Paso
como una alternativa lógica a un modo de
vida que se estaba quedando estancado
por otro lado la corrupción dentro del
Estado también ha jugado y juega un
papel muy importante en toda esta
historia de hecho en Ecuador no es
extraño encontrarse con noticias como
esta revelaron nexos entre marinos
Ecuatorianos y carteles del narcotráfico
la información de inteligencia revelada
por un medio ecuatoriano demuestra los
vínculos entre los miembros de la armada
del Ecuador y los grupos del tráfico de
droga sin embargo hubo dos eventos muy
específicos que facilitaron la extensión
del narco y la consiguiente violencia el
primero de ellos fue el cierre de la
base estadounidense de manta en el año
2009 por parte del gobierno correísta la
base de manta era crucial para poder
rastrear el tráfico de avionetas del
narcotráfico dentro del país sin ella
tuvieron vía libre pero seguramente el
factor más determinante para el
estallido de la violencia del
narcotráfico en Ecuador fue la firma del
acuerdo de paz entre las FARC y el
estado colombiano en el año 2016 y os
preguntaréis pero las FARC Colombia El
acuerdo de paz que día antes tienes todo
que ver con Ecuador no se supone además
que fue una buena noticia Pues Más allá
de si el acuerdo fue bueno o malo lo
cierto Es que tuvo importantes
repercusiones
Y es que veréis una vez que las FARC se
desmovilizaron la importante posición
que esta organización ocupaba en la
cadena de producción y distribución de
cocaína quedó huérfana Y qué creéis que
sucedió Exacto Que varios grupos del
narcotráfico incluidos muchos incidentes
de las propias FARC que no aceptaron el
acuerdo comenzaron a forjar alianzas con
cárteles mexicanos y otras
organizaciones europeas para asumir el
control El caso es que este auge de la
violencia del narcotráfico y las
constantes luchas por el control de las
rutas ha llevado a que Ecuador ya no sea
únicamente un país de tránsito como lo
era antes sino que ahora también es un
enclave operativo que resulta vital para
el refinamiento el almacenamiento y la
distribución internacional de drogas y
sabéis Quiénes han empezado a sacar
tajada de esta situación en el país
Exacto las pandillas las pandillas que
por cierto son las principales
responsables de la crisis de seguridad
que atraviesa este país desde el año
2021 y la pregunta es qué pasó en el año
2021 Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
pandillas y narcos
cuando uno se pone a echar un vistazo a
la evolución que ha tenido la crisis de
seguridad en Ecuador se da cuenta de una
cosa no es que el actual gobierno el de
lasso tenga ni muchísimo menos toda la
culpa de la dramática situación por la
que pasa el país en realidad ha sido la
inacción del anterior gobierno el de
Lenin Moreno la que ha sido realmente
devastadora Moreno como ya sabéis
sucedió a Correa en 2017 y vio de forma
prácticamente impasible como el crimen
se iba abriendo paso lentamente durante
toda su presidencia es más sabéis que
hizo para que intentar combatir el
progresivo aumento de la delincuencia y
de la violencia pues tomar medidas como
esta extinción del Ministerio de
Justicia preocupa a Defensores de
Derechos Humanos efectivamente lejos de
aumentar el presupuesto para luchar
contra la creciente violencia del narco
no se le ocurrió otra cosa mejor que
eliminar el Ministerio de Justicia y
reducir el presupuesto penitenciario
nada menos que un 30% y eso fue un error
un caso Error tras la adopción de estas
medidas el estado ecuatoriano comenzó a
perder el control sobre las presiones
que ya se estaban inundando de miles y
miles de pandilleros Y entonces las
cárceles comenzaron a convertirse en los
principales espacios de planificación
del crimen para las pandillas es más en
muchos casos llegaron a ser su centro de
operaciones y de hecho sabéis dónde
comenzó la oleada de violencia que más
tarde se extendió por todo el país
Exacto dentro de una cárcel pero ojo no
tan rápido porque para poder entender el
origen de esta crisis de seguridad
tenemos que detenernos en un actor
absolutamente clave La Pandilla de los
choneros
fundada en los años 90 por Jorge
bismarck beliz España conocido como El
chonero por ser natal de la ciudad de
chone esta pandilla comenzó como el
brazo armado de un cartel colombiano más
tarde Al comenzar el siglo XXI movió su
actividad a la ciudad costera de manta
donde empezó a enfrentarse con otras
pandillas como los queseros para
controlar las rutas del narcotráfico en
la costa del Pacífico en 2010 tres años
después de la muerte del chonero Jorge
Luis Zambrano conocido como rasquiña
pasó a liberar la pandilla a pesar de
estar tres rejas desde entonces los
choneros comenzaron a crecer hasta
convertirse en la pandilla carcelaria
más importante de todo el país hablamos
de un grupo que está Aliado al cártel de
Sinaloa de México y que desde el año
2007 llegó a dominar el tráfico de
narcóticos en el país
ahora bien sabéis lo que le acaba
pasando Todo imperio verdad todo lo que
sube termina por bajar y el caso de los
choneros no fue una excepción en
diciembre de 2020 el líder de la Banda
rasquiña fue asesinado mientras
disfrutaba de su libertad tomándose un
café en un centro comercial pues
entonces cuando empezó de verdad el
crecimiento exponencial de la
inseguridad en el país
Por qué Pues porque tras su asesinato
las reyertas entre pandillas dentro de
las cárceles se convirtieron en la norma
habitual durante 2021 y 2022 las
masacres se sucedieron dejando cientos
de reos muertos al final los choneros se
vieron debilitados por la rebelión de
dos de sus subestructuras conocidas como
los tiguerones y Los chone Killers que
eran su brazo armado poco a poco y pese
a los numerosos estados de excepción
declarados por el presidente lasso
durante la pandemia del covid el caos se
apoderó de las prisiones sin embargo la
violencia no se iba a limitar
exclusivamente las cárceles atentos
Ecuador sufre nueve atentados con
explosivos en un día cinco muertos y 16
heridos en un atentado con bomba en
Guayaquil Ecuador como os podéis
imaginar con semejante panorama no nos
puede extrañar que Ecuador haya superado
a México y a Colombia en cuanto a
muertos por cada 100.000 habitantes de
hecho en total en 2022 se produjeron
4500 homicidios pero sabéis que
seguramente el mejor reflejo de toda
esta desesperante situación de
inseguridad que está viviendo Ecuador en
estos momentos sea la ciudad costera de
Guayaquil conocida como la perla del
Pacífico se ha convertido en una de las
ciudades más sangrientas de todo el
continente y con diferencia la más
violenta de todo el país Ecuador entra
en la ruta latinoamericana del narco
Guayaquil ya supera en crímenes a Ciudad
Juárez Guayaquil se convirtió en uno de
los centros neurálgicos de la
distribución de cocaína y otros
narcóticos a nivel internacional de
hecho las embarcaciones que transportan
estos productos no solo llegan a
Centroamérica y Norteamérica sino que
también llegan a España y a otras partes
del norte de Europa y como os podéis
imaginar el hecho de que sea uno de los
principales puertos para la distribución
de droga ha hecho que la ciudad se
convierta en un auténtico campo de
batalla entre pandillas y entre carteles
aliados de hecho para que os hagáis una
idea más de la mitad de los 145
atentados con explosivos que se dieron
en el país solo entre enero y agosto de
2022 tuvieron lugar Precisamente en esta
ciudad en Guayaquil pero sea como sea si
algo está claro es que la noticia que
mejor representa la actual situación de
inseguridad y violencia que vive este
país es la del trágico asesinato de
Fernando villavicencio y ya sé lo que os
estaréis preguntando en estos momentos
pero quién era villavicencio y sobre
todo que nos muestra su asesinato pues
atentos
villavicencio la prueba del fracaso de
lasso
[Aplausos]
como seguro que todos Ya sabéis el
pasado día 10 de agosto de 2023 el
candidato presidencial Fernando
villavicencio fue asesinado a tiros tras
salir de un mitin político en el momento
de preparar Este vídeo las autoridades
Solo han podido detener a 6 colombianos
como responsables del atentado pero no
se ha descubierto Quién dio la orden y
Quién puso precio a su cabeza ahora bien
horas después del atentado circuló por
redes sociales un vídeo que rápidamente
se hizo viral era un vídeo de Una
Pandilla conocida como Los Lobos que se
atribuyó la autoría del atentado
nosotros la organización Los Lobos
asumimos la responsabilidad de los
hechos suscitados el asesinato de
villavicencio la tarde de hoy y Se
volverá a repetir cuando los corruptos
no cumplan su palabra Los Lobos que son
la segunda mayor agrupación delictiva
del Ecuador Es una de las principales
pandillas que participaron en las
masacres carcelarias de 2021 y 2022
esta pandilla que comenzó como una
disidencia de los choneros y que tiene
vínculos con el cartel mexicano de
Jalisco Nueva Generación ha ganado mucha
relevancia desde el año 2021 De hecho
cuando se unió a Los chone Killers y a
los tiguerones en su rebelión frente a
los choneros ganó un enorme peso en el
mundo del narcotráfico y de la minería
ilegal esta organización llegó incluso a
desterrar a los choneros de Guayaquil
por eso a primera vista aún no podría
asumir rápidamente que Los Lobos fueron
los autores reales sin embargo horas
después de que esto sacarán aquel vídeo
otro vídeo También se viralizó
rápidamente Y en este caso los hombres
que aparecían estaban a cara descubierta
y decían ser los verdaderos lobos y
negaban rotundamente la autoría del
atentado Nosotros somos
no nos tapamos las caras nadie Habla por
nosotros y si cumplimos con la paz
aclaramos y rechazamos el asesinato del
candidato a la presidencia el señor
Fernando villavicencio y por eso en el
momento en el que estamos preparando
Este vídeo todavía no se sabe con
exactitud quiénes o Quiénes estuvieron
detrás del asesinato
[Música]
lo que sí sabemos es que villavicencio
ya había denunciado una semana antes del
atentado que él mismo y su equipo de
campaña habían recibido claras amenazas
de muerte de Fito que es el líder de los
choneros y es un tipo estrechamente
vinculado al cartel de Sinaloa no
obstante a la espera de una
investigación más profunda lo único que
se conoce es la implicación directa de
aquellos seis ciudadanos colombianos sin
embargo aunque aún no sepamos la autoría
sí que podemos hacernos una pregunta por
qué villavicencio y no otro candidato
pensadlo bien a primera vista su
asesinato no tiene mucho sentido las
encuestas mostraban una tendencia
positiva pero todavía estaba muy lejos
de la Victoria y no parecía suponer una
amenaza política para nadie sin embargo
mis queridos amigos de la comunidad de
visualpolitik a pesar de su reducidas
opciones de convertirse en el próximo
presidente de Ecuador villavicencio era
ya bien conocido por haber sido una voz
especialmente incómoda para el
narcotráfico y los actores corruptos del
país policía siempre sabe dónde están
entonces en mi gobierno vamos a actuar
al revés quien ataca primero no va a ser
la delincuencia
nosotros vamos a atacar el mismo día que
yo me posicione voy a ordenar obviamente
tendré que sacar a las Manzanas podridas
que están al interior de la fuerza
pública ordenar vamos a atacar sabemos
las guaridas Dónde están los capos del
narco vacunadores extorsionadores
sicarios vamos a sacarlos de las
guaridas y los vamos a someter vamos a
combatir a narcotráfico como parte de
una estrategia transnacional la droga
que sale por este país el 90% sale por
los puertos de Guayaquil Así es que
vamos a militarizar los puertos de
Guayaquil vamos a poner escáneres en las
principales vías vamos a crear una
policía antimafias para someter a estos
grupos terroristas
su dura posición no era algo nuevo antes
de entrar en la política Fernando
villavicencio se desempeñó como
periodista independiente un tiempo
durante el cual investigó la corrupción
de gobiernos anteriores en especial la
del ejecutivo de Rafael Correa durante
su carrera como periodista presentó
numerosas denuncias contra altos
miembros del gobierno correísta e
incluso contra el propio expresidente
crítico con Rafael Correa fue
sentenciado en 2014 por difamación al
expresidente y en 2016 fue nuevamente
condenado a cárcel por supuestamente
revelar información confidencial que
había sido hackeada a la administración
de Correa en ambos casos huyó para no
cumplir las penas impuestas y a su
vuelta a Ecuador en 2017 tras la
Asunción de Lenin Moreno una de sus
investigaciones permitió abrir el
proceso penal que terminó condenando al
ex presidente huido a Bélgica a ocho
años de prisión por cargos de corrupción
[Música]
en general la gran mayoría de analistas
coinciden en que sus continuas denuncias
anticorrupción se habrían convertido en
una de las principales amenazas para el
funcionamiento de varias organizaciones
criminales y sus lazos con altos
funcionarios del gobierno de Ecuador esa
muy probablemente fue la causa de que lo
mataran
Al fin y al cabo villavicencio había
prometido una campaña sin cuartel contra
el crimen organizado y el narcotráfico y
se había comprometido a depurar a los
funcionarios corruptos del gobierno y de
la policía incluso había anunciado la
construcción de una cárcel de alta
seguridad en plena selva ahí se va a
construir esta cárcel de alta seguridad
donde serán trasladados Los Capos de la
delincuencia organizada
narcotraficantes secuestradores
vacunadores ahí estarán completamente
aislados No hay posibilidad de entrar
por otra vía que no sea la vía aérea
asustado con mi gobierno son los jueces
mafiosos la justicia de este país está
tomada por mafias desde hace años
tenemos que sacar a las mafias de la
justicia como lo vamos a hacer sin
embargo sabéis qué más prueba el
asesinato de villavicencio Además del
creciente poder de las pandillas y de
los narcos pues ni más ni menos que el
rotundo fracaso de la estrategia de
seguridad del presidente lasso como ya
sabéis la presidencia de lasso ha sido
todo un Calvario un bloqueo legislativo
insalvable La derrota en un referéndum
que el presidente convocó para intentar
ganar impulso político y la Inevitable
convocatoria anticipada de unas
elecciones que tendrán lugar este
domingo 20 de agosto y todo esto apenas
poco más de dos años después de haber
llegado al gobierno no obstante no solo
ha fracasado su plan de reformas por
falta de apoyos legislativos sino que
también ha fracasado en su lucha contra
la inseguridad del país que era otra de
sus grandes prioridades ahora bien cuál
fue exactamente su estrategia pues
Sencillamente declarar estados de
excepción dentro de las cárceles y luego
estados de emergencia para poder sacar
al ejército las ciudades como Guayaquil
y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo
ahora es tuvo éxito Pues por desgracia
los datos dicen que claramente no
Ecuador con récord de inseguridad en el
2023 entre el 1 de enero y el 20 de
marzo de 2022 las autoridades
contabilizaron 815 muertes violentas
mientras que en los mismos 78 días de
2023 hubo
1.356 esto supone un incremento del
66,4%. lasso llegó incluso a permitir la
tenencia y el porte de armas de uso
civil para la defensa personal una
protección tan inútil como inaccesible
para la mayoría de los ecuatorianos
sea como sea en el caso es que con
carácter general la estrategia de la
psoa fracasado pero no solo por las
medidas que él mismo ha decretado sino
también por los propios problemas de las
propias fuerzas de seguridad
ecuatorianas la realidad es que las
capacidades de investigación de la
policía no son precisamente las mejores
y la rotación de altos mandos policiales
ha creado demasiada inestabilidad en los
planes de seguridad y por si todo esto
fuera poco está también el tema de las
grandes sospechas de corrupción tanto en
el ejército como en la propia policía
así que ya lo veis mi querida comunidad
de visualpolitikatras quedarán los años
en los que Ecuador era un país
relativamente Pacífico hoy este pequeño
estado latinoamericano donde cada vez
tiene más peso las pandillas y el
narcotráfico se ha convertido en uno de
los más peligrosos de la región y del
mundo y sí el asesinato de villavicencio
es la mejor representación de esta
tragedia ahora la gran pregunta es si un
nuevo gobierno que salga de estas
próximas elecciones será capaz de frenar
esta espiral de violencia o si va a
terminar donde están sus vecinos Pero
llegados a este punto turno para
vosotros quién creéis que ha sido el
responsable del asesinato del candidato
villavi cencio Cómo pensáis que puede
Ecuador superar su crisis de inseguridad
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]